Yves, deine Kinder
sind mitten im Trotzalter.
Gibt es auch mal gesalzene Strafen?
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass meine Kinder
auch über Belohnung und Bestrafung
funktionieren - der Mensch generell.
Wir sind auch nur Tiere.
Die klassische Konditionierung
wie z.B. bei Hunden
funktioniert sehr gut.
Yves hält seine Kinder
ein wenig wie Hunde.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Die Frage des Strafens
ist philosophisch umstritten.
Darf man überhaupt strafen?
Was ist die Rechtfertigung
von Strafe?
Wenn man jemanden straft,
fügt man jemandem ein Übel zu.
Wenn man Übel zufügt,
muss man das rechtfertigen.
Wenn ich z.B. aus Notwehr handle,
wenn du mich erwürgen möchtest.
Ich darf dich schlagen,
weil du mich sonst umbringst.
Bei Strafen
stellt sich die Frage der Grundlage.
Man unterscheidet in der Philosophie
zwischen absoluten
und relativen Straftheorien.
Die absolute Straftheorie
schaut zurück und sagt:
Wenn du etwas Böses getan hast,
musst du das
dadurch entstandene Ungleichgewicht
wieder ins Gleichgewicht bringen.
Du musst etwas verbüssen,
dafür leiden.
Das ist das Wesen der Strafe.
Die relative Straftheorie
schaut in die Zukunft und sagt:
Beim Strafen geht es darum,
dass du es nicht nochmals machst.
Es geht um Abschreckung
und Prävention.
Das sind
zwei ganz unterschiedliche Ideen.
Du sagst, dich überzeugt
die absolute Straftheorie.
Intuitiv finde ich es plausibel.
Wenn jemand
Schuld auf sich geladen hat,
muss das ausgeglichen werden.
Er muss dafür büssen.
Es ist aber schwierig,
zu sagen, was das genau heisst.
Was bringt es wieder
ins Gleichgewicht?
Das ist auch total unklar.
Das hat die Philosophen
immer wieder umgetrieben.
Es ist ein metaphysisches Bild
eines Gleichgewichts.
Es ist nicht klar,
was das Strafmass ist.
Ein Vorschlag ist das Talionsprinzip.
Also: "Aug um Aug, Zahn um Zahn."
Es ist interessant:
Früher war das
ein zivilisatorischer Fortschritt.
Man hatte zumindest mal ein Prinzip.
Wenn du jemanden aus meiner Familie
umbringst, darf ich nicht
deine komplette Familie auslöschen.
- Nur jemanden.
Ja, nur jemanden.
Immanuel Kant fand, das stimme.
Er war auch für die Todesstrafe.
Das halte ich für Schwachsinn.
Die Todesstrafe
oder das Talionsprinzip?
Beides.
Hegel würde das auch sagen.
Er ist ein Anhänger
der absoluten Straftheorie.
Er sagt, es brauche
einen moralischen Ausgleich.
Aber er sagt, man müsse es
nicht mit demselben Mittel machen.
Wenn ich dich auf den Kopf schlage,
darfst du das nicht auch tun.
Du kannst mir
auch einfach 100 Fr. geben.
Der Wert muss gleich sein.
Wie kann man den Wert vergleichen?
- Schwierig.
- Reicht eine Entschuldigung?
Kommt darauf an,
wie fest du zugeschlagen hast.
Nehmen wir
einen Mörder oder Vergewaltiger
der im Gefängnis sitzt.
Wenn ich dir garantieren könnte,
dass er es nie wieder tut ...
Die Frage der Prävention
wäre vernachlässigbar.
Wenn man weiss,
dass er es nicht mehr tut.
Trotzdem finden wir,
er hat eine Strafe verdient für das,
was er getan hat.
Aber wozu?
Wenn er es nie mehr tut,
für wen ist die Busse dann?
Es geht nicht darum, ihn zu erziehen.
Das wäre wieder Prävention.
Es geht um das Gleichgewicht.
Ist das für die Opfer?
Ist es seltsam
oder schlimmer für das Opfer?
Geht es darum?
Es scheint mir alles
etwas metaphysisch angehaucht.
Mir ist nicht klar, was gemeint ist.
Deshalb verstehe ich, dass heute
die meisten Straftheoretiker
keine Anhänger
von absoluten Straftheorien sind.
Obwohl: Kürzlich habe ich
"Schindler's List" gesehen -
der Film von Spielberg.
Dort wird am Ende
einer der Drahtzieher des Holocausts
gehängt.
Das war so bei den Nürnberger
Prozessen - es gab die Todesstrafe.
Wenn man sich diesen Film anschaut,
hat man tatsächlich das Gefühl,
dass es nicht geht, zu sagen:
Wenn er es nie mehr macht,
lässt man ihn laufen.
Da ist etwas passiert,
wo ein Sühnegedanke mit reinkommt.
Der Mensch
ist ein gefühlsbasiertes Wesen.
Es gibt die Rachegefühle.
Oder ein starkes
Ungerechtigkeitsempfinden,
wenn der einfach so davonkommt.
Andererseits gibt es
starke Schuldgefühle bei Menschen,
die eine Tat begangen haben und
diese bereuen - wie in diesem Fall.
Vielleicht
ist die Strafe auch ein Mittel,
mit diesen Gefühlen zu haushalten.
Ein Surrogat für ein Verzeihen
beispielsweise.
Psychologisch
ist das sehr interessant.
Wir bestrafen uns auch selbst,
um dieses Gefühl loszuwerden.
Das Mittel, um Reue- oder Schuld-
gefühle loszuwerden, ist die Strafe.
Abbitte leisten - so nennt man das.
Ja. Es ist ein Umgang
mit diesen Emotionen.
Das Strafrecht muss sich in einer
Gesellschaft rechtfertigen lassen.
Was berechtigt uns, zu sagen, dass
der Staat Menschen bestrafen darf?
Das ist die Frage.
Selbst wenn sie es bereuen und
man weiss, dass sie es nie mehr tun.
Viele wechseln dann
zu den relativen Straftheorien.
Sie sagen, es gehe immer darum,
präventiv tätig zu sein.
Das ist bei meinen Kindern auch so.
Ich möchte beispielsweise, dass die
grössere Tochter es nicht mehr tut
und es die kleinere Tochter
nicht nachmacht.
Das sind zwei Sachen.
In der Philosophie
nennt man das Spezialprävention.
Du bestrafst die Grössere
und möchtest sie erziehen.
Generalprävention bedeutet,
ein Exempel zu statuieren.
Man bringt sie nicht hinter Gitter,
sondern in den Keller,
das hast du vorhin gesagt.
So wissen alle Kinder, auch
die Nachbarskinder, dass so was ...
- Generalprävention.
Die Abschreckung der Masse. - Ja.
Man zeigt: Wenn jemand das tut,
dann passiert das.
- Ja.
- Das ist sehr problematisch.
Wie viele Menschen
sind weltweit eingekerkert?
sitzen in Gefängnissen -
teils wegen Bagatellen?
Die Menschen
werden instrumentalisiert.
An wenigen
wird ein Exempel statuiert.
Man sperrt sie ein
und behandelt sie teils übel -
in der Hoffnung, abzuschrecken.
In ganz frühen Texten
der griechischen Antike
wird gesagt, dass die Religion
und das Leben nach dem Tod
genau deswegen erfunden wurde -
wegen der Moral.
Menschen,
die ein Scheiss-Leben geführt haben,
kommen
nicht einfach ungestraft davon.
Der Gedanke ist so stark,
dass das Jenseits erfunden wurde.
Es ist eine Knacknuss.
Das zeigt, dass darin
etwas Metaphysisches steckt.
Das Strafrecht sollte sich doch
von metaphysischen Ideen befreien.
Es sollte nicht darum gehen,
einen Sühnegedanken einzubauen.
Es sollte darum gehen, dass
weniger solche Taten verübt werden.
Der präventive Gedanke ist richtig.
Die Frage ist nur,
ob Strafe das richtige Mittel ist.
Auf rationaler Ebene stimmt das.
Aber die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung
hat solche Rachegefühle
und Intuitionen.
Die gingen auf die Barrikaden.
Es gäbe Selbstjustiz.
Vielleicht ist das Strafrecht
auch eine Beruhigung dieser Gefühle.
Man kann doch
kein Strafrecht etablieren,
weil die Menschen so kindisch sind
und Selbstjustiz ausüben würden.
Sicher.
Wenn die Konsequenzen
insgesamt besser sind - warum nicht?
Ein grosses Problem ist,
und das sieht man oft:
Menschen
drohen ihren Kindern dauernd,
ohne Konsequenzen folgen zu lassen.
Manchmal ist man froh,
dass keine Konsequenzen folgen.
"Tu das,
sonst sperre ich dich in den Keller."
Da ist man froh,
dass keine Konsequenz folgt.
Aber man konditioniert das Kind
dann falsch.
Egal, was es macht, die Drohung kommt
und es folgt nichts daraus.
Was mache ich dann als Elternteil?
Angenommen, ich erkläre,
warum man etwas nicht tun soll,
und es passiert trotzdem.
Dann habe ich das Gefühl,
dass sie spüren muss, was es heisst.
Es reicht dann nicht,
es nur zu sagen.
Grundsätzlich kann man mit einem Kind
vereinbaren, was die Regeln sind.
Man kann auch vereinbaren,
was geschieht,
wenn man sich nicht
an die Regeln hält.
- Das ist super.
- Dann ist das keine Drohung.
Man bespricht es gemeinsam.
Und dann folgt auch die Konsequenz.
Aber sie muss für das Kind
nachvollziehbar sein.
Grausam erscheint mir, wenn plötzlich
ein Übel auf das Kind runterdonnert
und es nicht versteht,
warum es derart einstecken muss -
ohne Vorwarnung.
Ja. Psychologische Studien zeigen,
dass das das Schlimmste ist:
Wenn man nie genau weiss,
was man falsch gemacht hat
und warum man so hart bestraft wird.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass es beim Bestrafen von Kindern
oft viel mehr
um die eigene Überforderung geht.
Man bräuchte vielleicht
selbst auch ein kurzes Time-out.
Manchmal geht es ganz gut, zu fragen,
warum es dem Kind so schwerfällt,
sich an die Regeln zu halten.
Dann stellt man halt die Musik
mal lauter und putzt zusammen.
Dann macht es auch Spass. Nächstes
Mal kommen sie selbst mit dem Besen.
Deine Kinder.
Darf man jetzt strafen oder nicht?
Schreiben Sie in die Kommentarspalte.
Bevor man bestraft wird,
tut man oft etwas Blödes oder Böses.
Über das Böse sprachen wir in der
"Sternstunde der Nacht" da drüben.
Und: Abonnieren Sie unseren Kanal.